[Music]
this time
uh
this hand depends what he does but he's
gonna
hit the ground pot so sometimes it's
here
sometimes it depends on what he does he
sees
he's doing something weird right now but
a lot of you kids do that
they grab like that but the intention
was that way
so this hand should not curve
so depending on what they do this hand
micro is down here
but it's still a projection
[Music]
so one man goes totally in one hand
finds the co2 vector
but that tokyo vector is not returning
him
[Music]
anyone that gets that far can run out
because
you have to follow the same pattern
so drop and pull
since that's the case your hips don't
rotate
in the throat lay down rotate you're
also going to double trip it
[Music]
you get the angle and then
he hits the ground at that
diagonal vector
[Music]
so okay you should try to run out if you
can
okay
okay let's look at why the uke
first appeared not to run out
he does that
so i set it up for that and then he does
that
it doesn't matter what you do okay if
you hold on to him
grab here still the same technology
doesn't matter
okay so what actually happened is
he he stopped his base
so that he could do his role and all
i've done now
is have him don't stop your face
just keep your face going see if you can
run
through that's all i have to do
now if you look at what i'm doing
he's going around me now he passed me
he's going around me he passes
around passing around
why did the other one work because just
on him
he stopped going around
because he took the roll he plants that
foot then
i accelerate him
but if he doesn't stop
are you gonna i'm gonna stop him well
that's a clash
that arm's going that way no holding it
in here so you can go
like that still try to go around me even
though i have your arm
so he can't pass me
and my throws acceleration
i have to create the tilt there's the
tilt
and then because the chicago's back here
that's where the throw goes
when you combine it in motion
he doesn't pass me and then the throw
starts
[Music]
oh
okay
it's very common you want to do your hip
rotation
and you want to do your double pivot
then you want to accelerate them this is
not like you know
it's not what we do okay
so watch things that make you
have to do that okay if i pull my arm up
like that
he's closing the gap it's one of the
things you do
when uh he's close
so he's close it's going to be hard to
do that round kick here
but i can come up and hit with a
crescent i can
seek vertical height and not be
compacted by the range but he's close so
when you change your vertical
he's actually getting closer he's
allowed to get closer
so you want that big line up
he's moving close you see and by the
time i get his passenger
on this version that's going to be
a lot of trouble whoa you're like
on but he's already passed
second one is you believe
he's out here now
so this version we did here was just
here
and this hand with that movement starts
to go down immediately
it doesn't go up down
it moves down down
then if i don't have the projection
that's going to be
a hard stuff okay can't get rid of that
[Music]
hey
oh you're trapped by the x y
so just like any simple technique and
then you picture this
that big acidity
and then you can't ever get you you
can't ever get there
can't get there in real life okay this
is
pretty um so we do things like
we do the technique here
so i brought him in a circle so i get
used to the idea that he has to move in
a certain way then eb opens it's no
different
the opening has to present itself i
don't create the opening the opening has
to present
itself okay so so uh he does the strike
right and i'm here like this and then
pause
[Music]
it could be something like that right
he's trying to grab
he's grabbing me i do my deviation he
comes back in
right go back it comes back in and then
i have my id
so the opening has to present itself
and x y never does it
x y is you create an opening this is not
jiu-jitsu okay so
uh i'm doing this technique here
and you're thinking x y so
i get out of the way
instead don't don't try to throw him in
here
start the whole technique rotating
especially if you're going to do the
edibi
so well here
there's no rule why he has to go that
way
why he has to stay on that
he has to go around you know he went
around with me but if he goes too far
this is not the technique
so technique is here
have more the feeling of what you're
doing so
yen boom project
then then you can enter
you can yield
it doesn't matter but you can't have the
guy past you
and then you're gonna try to do that
okay
so free yourself
and let him do the opening so he's
he's trying to displace me joe
boom he's trying to do that so
our first move is good luck
start the fire rotating
rotate
angle push right that line
too late
so your technique can start being
quicker all right
look at the difference
just quick
okay let's try it again
you